- Good evening all, Srini Seshadri,
global head of Financial
Services for HCL Tech
AWS has been a great partner for us
and we've just recently
signed an FS-specific SCA.
We've also partnered with
Commonwealth Bank of Australia
for the last almost two decades
and we are extremely thrilled
to have Terri Sutherland,
who's the general manager for
data platforms and operations.
She oversaw what is probably
the largest data migration
in the southern hemisphere,
and we look forward
to hearing insights from her
on this pathbreaking platform,
as well as other insights
on data modernization.
Once again, Terri Sutherland, please.
- Thank you, Srini. Hello, everyone.
I'm Terri Sutherland, general manager
of the Enterprise Data Platforms
at the Commonwealth Bank of Australia,
and I'm super excited to be here
with you today to talk about
our enterprise data platform modernization
and our strategic partnership with HCL
and how we achieve the
largest and fastest migration
in the southern hemisphere.
But first, let me tell
you about the bank itself.
Though many of you may never have heard
of the Commonwealth Bank
of Australia, or CBA,
as we call it, we are
Australia's largest bank.
Australia's population is 27 million,
and today, CBA services
17.5 million customers,
which means one in three Australians
and one in four businesses bank with us.
Overall, 50% of Australia's
transactions go through CBA.
And on the global stage,
we are the 13th largest
bank by market value.
And I'm very excited to say
that we've just been named
the top four bank globally
for AI maturity.
I'd like to talk to you to you briefly
about our data strategy
and then how the data platform
modernization fits in.
At the heart of our transformation,
are three core pillars:
people, safeguards, and technology.
On people, we recognize
that a centralized data
team couldn't keep pace
with our business demand to scale on AI.
So we embedded data engineers
and data scientists directly
into the lines of business,
bringing data closer to
the people who use it
and closer to the people
we serve, our customers.
As a bank, safeguards are non-negotiable,
so we embedded governance
and risk controls
at every stage of the
data in AI lifecycle,
ensuring safety by design.
And lastly on technology,
we needed to connect decades
of rich data spread across hundreds
of source systems to empower
our federated data teams
on the latest tooling.
To achieve this, we established
a data mesh ecosystem
on AWS cloud that empowers
our federated teams
to operate independently, move data,
and use data seamlessly,
all the while, enforcing
strict governance.
We call this ecosystem CommBank.data.
Today, it empowers 40 lines of business,
the freedom to produce
and use data as needed
within a trusted and controlled framework.
To enable this, we decentralized
and adopted a clear
producer-consumer model.
Each business unit now builds, owns,
and manages its data as a product
with defined roles and responsibilities.
We've also introduced
self-service data sharing
through a unified data
marketplace, a single pane of glass
where users can discover, request,
and consume data across
the entire AWS ecosystem.
However, that said, data has gravity
and where the data lives is
where every data scientist
and data engineer in the bank will work.
Historically, CBA held years
of rich data held in on-premise platforms
that lacked interoperability
and could not scale for AI.
And so we made a bold move.
We migrated 61,000 on-premise pipelines
to our AWS mesh ecosystem.
That's equivalent to 10 petabytes of data.
The migration took nine
months with a hundred percent
of data pipelines tested three times,
that's 229,000 tests.
And in so doing, we moved
our entire data engineering
and AI workforce to AWS cloud.
So how do we do such a
large migration so quickly?
This is where our partnership
with AWS and HCL comes in.
Oops, sorry.
Early last year, we kicked off a series
of workshops with AWS and HCL
to test our most complex data pipelines
and AI use cases to see if the migration
to AWS native technologies was possible.
We call this approach steel threads.
Unlike a proof of concept or an MVP,
steel threads prove the technology,
but they also productionalize the outcome.
Working closely with HCL, we built AI
and generative AI that transform
code, check for errors,
and then tested the output,
reconciling the tables exactly
to our on-premise platform 100%.
Every single row, column, and number
needed to be accounted for.
Throughout the nine month
migration, CBA, AWS,
and HCL worked closely as
a unified tight knit team.
We adopted this approach to
stop any potential misalignment,
often associated with big programs of work
and ambitious deadlines.
We prioritized establishing
a shared purpose
and operating cadence,
ensuring each member
of the team felt a real sense
of ownership toward
achieving our common goal.
And now, with our AWS
mesh ecosystem in place
and evolving our on-premise migration
to that ecosystem in place and complete,
we are ready to scale on
CBAs ambitious AI-powered,
data driven-future.
Would like hand over to Pukhi.
I'll grab you this.
- Thank you, Terri for
sharing the insights.
I'm Puneet Makhija, delivery partner
at HCL Tech, leading high performing teams
delivering solutions at CBA.
Let me dive into some of
the critical success factors
that were for this migration.
Best in class and fit for
purpose engineering practices.
At HCL Tech, engineering is at the core
of everything what we do.
Industry is seeing a conversions of data,
AI, and engineering,
and we leverage best practices
across these paradigms
for this program.
We began early, strategically sourcing
and deploying talent in phases
to access the ideal talent pool.
The data and AI lab created an environment
that encouraged learning
and innovation, helping teams to adapt
to the program requirements.
We improved test and migration quality
in each sprint by use
matrices and track progress.
Delivery construct for this program
was truly outcome-based.
Cognitive team topologies.
We organized the teams
according to the Dreyfus
Competency Framework,
which helped us create a
cognitive diverse team structure.
Connect pods led enablement,
scale migration, and automation
and acceleration spots across the program.
Elite AI engineers were
embedded in the teams
to foster creative tension
and consistently identify
ways to accelerate.
Engineering skills uplift
and transformation levers.
We ramped up our engineering team early,
peaking at over 250
AWS-certified data engineers.
We began upskilling and
certifications early,
so our team was ready and effective
from start of the migration.
We shifted from specialized roles
to full cycle engineering,
aligned to CBS model
to deliver solutions effectively.
In short, we used three
transformation levers:
AWS certification for engineers,
focused on full cycle engineering
and AI-driven automation.
Automation and Gen AI.
Developing automation
accelerators of parallel testing
enabled us successful
migration of 61,000 pipelines
and over 10 petabytes of data
over to AWS in less than
nine months with precision
and meeting quality objectives.
An important takeaway from this migration
is that we are committed to
incorporating AI accelerators
for all future transitions
and legacy migration initiatives.
We are working towards bringing
the agent-led delivery cycle,
ALDC to life in future.
As an organization,
we have embraced future-fit delivery model
as minimum standard for
any search initiative.
Last, but one of the significant
critical success factors,
HC Tech strategic partnership with AWS.
A significant factor in our success
has been the strategic
partnership with AWS
and a strong collaboration top down.
The mantra, One Team One
Dream united CBA, AWS,
and HCL Tech, leading to
the program's success.
This achievement marks
the first of its kind,
and we look forward to
future collaborations.
Thank you.
- [Participant] All right.
(people applaud)